In this video, we're going to cover what
Open Sound Control is,
where it came from, and its many use cases.
Open Sound Control is
a data transport specification similar to MIDI or DMX,
and it's for real-time message communication
among many different kinds of application and hardware.
This is often referred to as peer-to-peer messaging,
and this works not just in Unreal Engine,
but in a wide variety of different softwares,
including QLab, TouchOSC, MaxMSP, and many, many more.
We've used OSC in many cases,
not just to send simple messages back and forth,
but even to utilize a fairly robust multiplayer setup
without having to deal with the limitations
of a server-client relationship in a traditional sense,
such as where when a server crashes,
the clients are no longer able to stay in a session.
Through OSC, as you'll see,
we can send signals as needed,
and if anything goes wrong with those signals,
they can simply be sent again,
and because none of the quote-unquote clients
inside the session are actually being hosted
by a traditional server, there's no problem
if anything goes wrong with that server.
It can always come back and send those messages once more.
To add on to that,
the way we use it to replace our traditional multiplayer,
OSC give us a lot more flexibility.
We can be selective about the things we want to send,
and because we're not bind to a traditional server,
we can be very flexible about our session.
Sometimes we can have a session still running
without a server.
We can have multiple computer being the server.
That's a lot of more flexibility and benefit
comes from using OSC as a communication method.
OSC, again, refers to open sound control,
which is unfortunately a bit of a misnomer
because OSC can be used for a wide variety of purposes.
We can send integers, strings, floats,
a wide variety of different kinds of signals
besides just sound,
but OSC was basically developed
to be an alternative to MIDI.
Anyone who's played on a keyboard piano before
has probably heard of MIDI
in the way that you can send music signals to a computer.
Well, MIDI was pretty limited
in terms of how it was able to send messages,
so OSC was designed essentially to be a more robust way
to send different kinds of messages with more complexity
and is now widely used across a wide variety
of industries.
Some of the benefits of OSC compared to MIDI
include a higher resolution
because OSC can send full floating point numbers
and a wide variety of other data types,
and MIDI 7-bit messaging is highly limited
by what it can do.
We have flexible addressing
because OSC messages can be structured with a hierarchy,
kind of like URLs,
which allows for much more organized
and descriptive communication.
We also have extensibility
because users can define their own message formats
and address spaces,
as you'll see the way that a OSC message is sent
looks a lot like a directory or URL,
and that makes it adaptable
to a wide variety of applications
beyond just sound and music.
And lastly, here we mentioned
that we have network centric design
because OSC was designed
with a modern networking infrastructure,
well past when MIDI was created
where networking was much more limited.
And so it's a well-suited format
for any kind of internet or land-based communication.
And what June and I will be showing you today
involves both sending messages locally
when you're on the same subnet,
as well as opening up ports
and sending data across the internet.
As previously mentioned,
OSC can be used across a very wide variety of industries
such as music production,
theatrical and live show control, performance capture,
virtual production, and interactive art.
Here on this page,
we have an example of a show
that June and I were involved with
with our company Agile Lens a few years ago,
a Christmas Carol VR.
And the way that this show was able to function
was cues were able to fire
from another piece of software called TouchOSC,
basically mimicking the same cue board
that we had constructed inside Unreal Engine 4.27,
which meant that if there was anything wrong
with the host who was sending out cues in Unreal Engine,
we could actually send out exactly the same signals
from this other software,
which could run on Windows or Mac
or even something like an iPad,
just allowing for a much more robust
and flexible way to control the show.
In the next video,
we'll look at some of the core concepts of OSC,
including how it gets implemented directly
in Unreal Engine.